[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh keith hernandez the mets color
analyst for uh
sports new york uh sny and uh
former batting champ a little
controversy yesterday michael conforto
leaned into a pitch
bases loaded ninth inning a walk-off hit
by pitch and uh keith kind enough to
join us
uh walk me through that at bat keith
how it started and then how it ended
well
uh there was two strikes bases loaded
obviously i forget the count it might
have
one three one two one two um
the pitch was clearly going to be a
strike i did not see
i think gary cohn our play-by-play guy
are ron darling our my other analysts in
the booth saw the umpire raising a right
hand
to make called third strike okay
uh i notice because i'm watching
conforto
move his elbow in at the last minute
you can't do that that's not
that's not legal and uh it should have
been a strike three now the rule
i got sent by baseball academy this
morning
i'll read you the rule but it it doesn't
stay it's a little
big it's not it's not ambiguous just
right to the point if the ball
is in the strike zone when it touches
the batter
it shall be called a strike whether or
not the batter tries to avoid the ball
if the batter if the ball is outside the
strike zone when it touches the batter
it shall be called a ball
if he makes no attempt to avoid being
touched
but what it doesn't say is what's the
rule about a hitter
going in intentionally
to get hit whether it's out of the
strike zone or in the strike so
the pitch was a strike so by the rule it
clearly should have been
a strike three but besides the point the
big point is
you allow all these players with this
armor on their elbow
you know i got hit in my elbow it's no
fun and it hurts there
and you better put ice on it quick or
it's going to balloon up and you're
going to miss a couple games
fortunately i had ron hunt as my when i
was 19 years old in my first big league
camp
he was my roommate and he taught me the
the icing for 24 hours overnight after
you got hit on a joint
so you will do so you'll play the next
day but with the armor you're allowing
a lot of hitters and i see it they don't
move moving it's very rare if you see
someone move into the ball
but they don't move so the ball is
inside
six and seven inches they don't attempt
to get out of the way and that's
perfectly legal not to move
but you cannot intentionally go in to
get hit by a pitch
and it was very clear on the on the
replay now
the second base umpire has the view too
as a
has the has a good view uh the opposite
view of the home plate umpire
he could have overruled now i thought
gary cohen made a great call because
i we got a list of uh calls
that can be challengeable and what calls
can be
gary knew right away that a hit by pitch
is challengeable
but that wasn't the call
challenge mattingly can challenge he got
hit by a pitch
but you can't it's a umpire's judgment
where the
the ball the hitter uh moved
deliberately to get hit
uh but it was apparent the pitch was a
strike
and so the umpire behind the plate run
culpa blew the call
if he was raising his right arm to call
it a strike
then by the rule we just read
that strike three do you have a problem
with what conforto did
yes i do i don't i think um
if you were just talking about back in
our day
but he's helping his team win though
keith like whatever it takes
i don't i don't have any problem with it
because it's up to the umpire to police
the game
guys cheat all the time i understand so
i don't know the umpire blew the call
that would uh upset a lot of people on
the opposing team and i'm
very curious to see saturday uh
how this unfolds uh
when conforto gets up the first time i i
don't think anything's gonna happen
um but i know that
steve carlton told me a great story
about ron hunt and you know he got hit
all he had the body armor
and carlton said i was winning five six
nothing in the
in the eighth inning and
hunt was leading off and he said i know
he's gonna
foul off eight pitches so i just hit him
on the first pitch
and let him go to first base i did so i
didn't spend any bullets
which i thought was just hilarious yeah
so um because ron got hit over 200 times
in his career
the all-time leader did bgo end up
passing him i don't know i don't know
don balor was up there too
don got hit a lot also and there was no
body armor in those days for for don
so uh so anyway
are you okay if the marlins hit conforto
on saturday
am i okay with it yeah i would be okay
with it
and we'll see if there's a brawl you
know i i don't know
uh i'm sure umpires will i don't i don't
know how it's going to happen i
i just don't think it's going to happen
with in today's game
i don't think it's going to happen
it was wild yesterday because i'm
watching and i'm going
and i was right there with you and ron i
i didn't know what the rule was i
thought well just
check replay and then you could only
check replay to see if he got hit
but you know ron had already culpa had
already made his call
so i well he could have been overruled a
second base
umpire or the first but how much time
had to elapse though keith before
he could do it because the membership
they conferred they conferred
yeah and the first base umpire is not
going to have a view because
conforto's back to him second base has
the best view
and third base could have made the call
as well but
i just think umpires are regulated so
much then
and i think that to me they're looking
over their shoulder
so much that they are are petrified
sometimes to make a call
because they're being observed uh and
can you feed
your cat keith ken what's wrong with
that
um he's
a marlins fan he loves uh seafood he
loves fish
right so um uh
i just think you know it was one time in
my career where
we had a lot of good umpires in the
national league but we had a handful of
bad ones
and they took a poll and the poll the
league decided
take a poll to players coaches and
managers
uh and rate the umpires now you can have
a player or a manager or a coach
that has a grudge against a certain
umpire but
when you have over 900 players i think
you're going to get a
a a a fair assessment of a rating of the
umpires
and like any business there are if you
have an incompetent employee you get rid
of them
higher competent umpires and i think
there's a lot of them out there but
there's always a scattering of bad ones
we'd weed them out and i also feel that
you need umpires have got to be have the
courage of their convictions
and i think with with the today's game
with the challenges and the instant
replay
number one it's a crutch for the umpires
you know if i'm
doing my job i don't want to be
overruled i'd be embarrassed
if i made a bad call and consistently i
i would be embarrassed
by that and i would step it up you know
and step up my performance
but i think it becomes a crutch where
the umpires we see it i i just
kind of see him getting lazy and he said
well i get it wrong
blah blah blah it'll it you know and i i
don't i don't like that i don't like
challenges too because it
we're trying to speed up the game and it
begins become a game of bullpens and
that's why the game has become so long
and you've got eight guys out in
bullpens
and you cannot give me eight eight eight
guys that uh just pet them
eight guys you can't give me eight guys
that are all gonna be
great relievers there's gonna be some
soft spots and there's a lot of guys
that throw hard that don't have command
and a lot of 3-2 counts and i understand
why the games become a bullpen game and
that's why the games are longer
because the pitching changes so who
wants to
have the challenge i mean how many i can
tell you how many games
there were it's the final play at the
plate and the runner's safe and
everybody's
and it's challenge and you gotta wait
what three
four minutes for the game to be
officially over i i just
hate that it's it it used to be instant
replay remember when we were growing up
now it's just replay because
it takes forever with replay we're
talking to keith hernandez
and his daughter his dog his cat uh
[ __ ] [ __ ] is needy man
he is one of the he's he's like a dog
you guys have the same kind of hair
color by the way
[Laughter]
hey i was talking to jeff perlman and he
wrote a book on the 86 match he wrote
a book on showtime lakers showtime
lakers going to hbo and they're going to
make a series out of it
do you think that they would ever do uh
like a mid 80s mets
you know kind of uh series like tv
series
oh a tv series yeah oh god i
i i don't know i know that espn's gonna
did a bit of
did a big is doing a big documentary on
the 86 guy was interviewed
uh two winters ago
and they're doing a one of those whether
there's a 20 20 or whatever it is 30
30 30 30 30 they're gonna have a thing
on the 86 mets which i'm kind of looking
forward to but you could make a tv
series out of the 86 minutes
you can do it on the bronx zoo too in
the 70s yeah
yeah well i wasn't around the bronx zoo
i was around the 86 mets and
man you guys led the league for you dan
uh
gonna be 65. yeah i'm only two years
older than you
yeah yeah we were around we were aware
of what the bronx it was about
yeah but i but i wasn't around it i was
around you guys
like you can draw social security now
how about you look at you
i know i know i'm getting up there i got
to get me a cat too
i gotta i uh yeah sure make that work
here uh the mets continue their series
against the marlins tomorrow at citi
field
jacob degrom oh no
he's going to go probably six quality
innings
give up one run four hits no decision
or lose the game keith well it's
incredible that he doesn't get a lot of
runs and it's been kind of like when i
was a kid growing up
when san francisco was gaylord perry
gaylord perry was the hard luck pitcher
for the giants who always lose two to
one
three to two uh lose those close games
and degrom has taken it to a to a new
level
i think a lot of it was had to do with
the uh covet outbreak on the nationals
he was supposed to pitch the real
opening day
and he got put back and they they didn't
know if they were going to play
the next day or the next day so he
couldn't do his
sideline so they made a decision on
sick not pitches just six innings and i
disagree i
i i you know i miss the pitchers going
nine innings
but you get these guys nolan ryan didn't
get a lot of support and they said well
you know his
players got bored because it was either
strikeout or a walk when nolan was on
the mound
sid fernandez it felt like had a
no-hitter through five innings every
time
i saw him pitch for the meds they're
just certain pitchers who
don't get off i don't know how you
explain it that they don't get run
support
you know what it was when we were on the
road or it was getaway day
it was like we didn't want sid pitching
getaway day
we wanted to get one doc out there get
on that airplane and get to the next
town
[Laughter]
sid was going to take forever well
he's got a lot of he got a lot of swings
and misses oh he did
he got as many swings and misses as
anybody i remember if you look at
like per pitch how many swings and
misses sid fernando's got a ton of those
man yes yeah well he had 200 strikeouts
a lot of
more than a few times in his career he
was uh and it was fun to watch pitch
because he was just so
unusual his stuff his physique
it doesn't matter that's the beauty of
baseball i know well look at schilling
he had one of the worst bodies and he
was a great pitcher and you got
you know you got you don't have to be
six foot four
you can be like freddy patek we're not
we're not being contemporary here
no all the players today are six five
and six six i mean they're just i'm six
feet tall and i feel like i am
i'm dwarfed by them yeah yeah
uh hey it's great to talk to you have
fun uh my best to uh
uh ronnie and hope uh hopefully have
a little bit of drama on saturday not
too much drama on saturday
yep and we'll see and feed [ __ ] okay i i
did
i'll feed him again just for you thank
you that's all right
keith